[Música]
vivimos en una época de estancamiento
de rápido empobrecimiento de algunas
poblaciones
en un aumento de las desigualdades y de
grandes desastres ecológicos
porque no podemos escuchar el llamado
del planeta
el planeta nos está diciendo todos los
días en cada rincón del mundo nos está
haciendo llamadas de alerta
vemos huracanes terremotos varios
llamados distintos llamados
deslizamientos pero no respondemos
los seres humanos no estamos haciendo
nada
el futuro es incierto
el planeta es nuestro único hogar
y no lo estamos escuchando lo que les
decía antes
los seres humanos estamos alterando
la naturaleza el mundo natural y de esa
manera estamos acelerando la extinción
del mismo
sabemos que nos estamos precipitando a
un abismo y tampoco hacemos nada para
frenarlo
vivimos en un planeta finito
con recursos limitados y aún así
pretendemos
crecer ilimitadamente
les había hablado de la sobrepoblación
la sobrepoblación es un gran problema en
es uno de los orígenes del problema de
los cambios del problema actual de la
crisis climática actual planetaria
estamos sobre poblados
en siete meses del año estamos
utilizando los recursos que el planeta
nos puede dar en un año
utilizamos actualmente en siete meses
por lo tanto estamos en una deuda con el
planeta de cinco meses este año y es una
deuda que se va a ir a como acumulando
hay soluciones obvias para parar la
sobrepoblación y hasta en algo para eso
se trata de una ideología ciega o de una
ignorancia deliberada para mediar la
tremenda la grave crisis climática que
está ocurriendo en el planeta
75% hoy por hoy 75 del medioambiente
terrestre un 40 por ciento del
medioambiente marino
y un 50% de los arroyos se encuentran
severamente dañadas y no podemos negar
y la grave crisis y desaparición de las
otras especies que existen en el planeta
actualmente
ya estamos en plena siesta extinción
masiva
un 75% de los insectos ya ha
desaparecido un 43% de los anfibios
también en general un 50% de los
animales han desaparecido
a más de un millón de especies de
animales y de plantas se han extinguido
ahora mismo
12 de octubre de 2019
a eso tenemos que añadir lo que está
sucediendo en el país
tremendos incendios en la chiquitanía en
la amazonía lo mismo en el brasil
y cada país pues tiene en el año una
cuota de vuelo de carbono que debemos
cumplir es un palo irónico pero todos
tenemos una cuota de huella de carbono
lo mismo cada uno de los seres humanos
bueno en 15 días de incendio bolivia
cumplido la cuota que debería haber
cumplido en un año o sea que imagínense
la cantidad de emisión de co2 que se han
llevado a la atmósfera solamente en
bolivia por lo tanto esto está afectando
no solamente a bolivia sino al resto del
planeta
hay un ejemplo muy ilustrativo de un
filósofo griego francés que se llama
cornelius castoriadis
con el ejemplo de un padre de familia a
quien los médicos le avisan que es muy
posible que su hijo tiene una enfermedad
muy grave lo que corresponde que haga el
padre es que ponga a su hijo en manos de
especialistas y humanos de los mejores
médicos que le puedan confirmar si ese
diagnóstico es certero o no
lo que no debería ser ese padre es
pensar de la siguiente manera
bueno si me han dicho que mi hijo tiene
una enfermedad grave
que posiblemente tengo una enfermedad
grave también puede ser posible que no
la tenga por lo tanto mejor espero me
espero de brazos cruzados y eso es lo
que exactamente estamos haciendo los
seres humanos
el planeta está enfermo
y no estamos haciendo nada para curarlo
nos estamos estamos cruzando los brazos
y estamos esperando a que llegue el fin
por eso es importante que no dependamos
de posibilidades o especulaciones
lo que nos dice la ciencia es eso
estamos al borde del abismo y es
importante que actuemos ya hoy o ayer
si no hacemos eso si no cambiamos de
rumbo si no cambiamos de modelo
económico
vamos estaban vamos a perder el planeta
o por lo menos se va a acabar la
civilización la realidad es que somos
adictos al crecimiento económico
estamos obsesionados con el consumo
cada vez consumimos más queremos tener
más cosas más de todo
eso es el crecimiento económico para
nosotros
y esta adicción nos está llevando
nos está llevando a
a poner en riesgo lo que va a venir en
el futuro para las futuras generaciones
yo les pregunto a ustedes estamos
adictos al consumo queremos comprar más
cosas realmente en comprar las cosas que
realmente no necesitamos no tienes
pregunta ustedes necesitan realmente
tener 10 pares de zapatos o 15 pares de
zapatos en nuestro en nuestro ropero o 5
pares de jeans realmente necesitamos eso
pero entramos no hacia el consumo es
impresionante hay gente que además tiene
algunos problemas de adicción en las
compras no esa sensación de inicia de
satisfacción cuando consumimos que el
rato de comprar es una sensación que es
como cuando entramos a
al tren fantasma es como cuando entramos
a la montaña rusa
es una especie de emoción que sentimos
cuando estamos comprando más y más nos
encanta pero luego entramos a la casa
del terror salimos y hay esa sensación
de vacío
y también vacío de nuestros bolsillos
porque por comprar y comprar y comprar
nos estamos endeudando
yo quiero que me digan aquí aquellos que
tiene el préstamo bancario como es
cuando uno se endeuda la vida se pasa
más rápido porque tenemos que comprar
cuando ver cumplir con los plazos que
nos da el banco y de pronto tenemos que
pagar el 10 de febrero y de pronto 16 de
marzo y tenemos que ver de dónde
conseguimos y después en fines de abril
y 10 de mayo se nos pasó el año y hemos
pasado preocupados para ver cómo vamos a
cumplir con esa deuda
entonces la adicción nos trae también
endeudamiento y empezamos a vivir una
vida de esclavos nos esclavizamos
tener más
consumo más dinero más cosas
para conseguir menos menos y menos cada
vez
menos tiempo para disfrutar con nuestra
familia menos tiempo para estar en casa
menos tiempo para descansar menos tiempo
para disfrutar de la sencillez de cada
día menos tiempo para ocuparnos de
nuestra propia salud
porque tenemos que estar gastar más y
más y más y vivir más
pero no sé por qué les preguntó ustedes
tenemos
queremos un nuevo
de tener menos
no podemos concebir la felicidad
teniendo menos pero en realidad - no
quiere decir carencia no quiere decir
que no tengamos cosas
- quiere decir tener menos estrés menos
ansiedad menos preocupaciones para tener
más felicidad y más libertad
vamos a cambiar y vamos a hablar de
algunas oportunidades
de otros objetivos porque a los adictos
nos en este caso son los adictos al
consumo a los adictos no nos gusta que
nos digan que nuestro hábito es malo no
es cierto le encontramos mil razones mil
disculpas y bueno lo que no importa es
que nos digan que otras alternativas hay
y ahí empezamos a abrirnos un poco bueno
vamos a llegar a esto que son los
objetivos de desarrollo económico y de
desarrollo sostenible perdón que en 2015
193 países aprobaron la agenda 2030 que
replantear estos objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible se abrió un nuevo horizonte
para el ser humano para los gobiernos
aparentemente es espectacular 17 tenemos
17 objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
que sirven no solamente para los
gobiernos debería servir también para
nosotros individuos por ejemplo si
queremos trabajar para disminuir la
pobreza podemos trabajar en el objetivo
sostenible número 1 si queremos ayudar
en el tema del cambio climático nos
vamos al objetivo número 13 pero si
vemos detenidamente cada objetivo hay
algunos problemitas y hay un problemita
que es el más grande de todos estos
objetivos y es el número 8 dice trabajo
decente y crecimiento económico
otra vez crecimiento económico el lado
oscuro de esta propuesta el lado oscuro
de este modelo que nos han convencido
que es el modelo que nos va a llevar al
2030 pero nosotros no podemos pedirle al
modelo que no se está hundiendo como
planeta que nos salve
no es cierto o sea no podemos hacer eso
entonces por lo tanto una de las cosas
que tenemos que hacer es cambiar de
modelo económico
esto que sonaba tan lindo haber sido el
problema no la solución el crecimiento
económico es el problema no la solución
hay diferentes tipos de economía está la
economía circular la economía solidaria
economía ecológica la teoría del
decrecimiento que nos ayuda a tejer una
alfombra con muchas soluciones para
salvar la situación actual entonces no
es que no hay una alternativa al
crecimiento económico
[Música]
y yo les voy a contar a raíz de esto un
cuento de unos misioneros que llegan a
la amazonía
esos misioneros llegan y se encuentran
con una tribu en la amazonía que está
recolectando leña a mano
y entonces están dedicados a recolectar
leña y les dicen
nosotros tenemos unos machetes que les
podemos dejar unos buenísimos machetes y
si ustedes utilizan estos machetes van a
recolectar leña mucho más rápido y
obviamente tener más leña
entonces si les dejan los machetes
y luego después de un par de años estos
misioneros vuelven
vuelven a la misma comunidad y les
preguntan cómo les ha ido en la
recolección de leña con los machetes
la comunidad les contesta que les ha ido
muy bien porque ahora
recolectan leña en mucho menos tiempo de
lo que recolectaban antes los misioneros
dicen que viene
eso quiere decir que tienen mucha más
línea
y los comunarios se contesten le dicen
tenemos la misma cantidad de leña lo que
tenemos es mucho más tiempo para estar
con la familia para hacer caminatas para
disfrutar para meternos al río
y se dan cuenta de la diferencia que hay
en medir las cosas
nos hemos nos han acostumbrado a medir
todo con la vara del dinero cuánto ganas
tú
cuánto produce es cuánto exportar para
el dinero de los números
en proyectos en diferentes proyectos es
mejor el que más gasta no se mide la
eficiencia del proyecto la cantidad de
dinero que se ha gastado para bien está
midiendo el impacto el bienestar de la
gente
en el lado bueno
en el lado positivo
un gran cambio está floreciendo miren el
movimiento mundial de los jóvenes
en todas partes del mundo
están los jóvenes que salen a las calles
a reclamar por un futuro que están
cuestionando el modelo actual que están
cuestionando el consumo y están
cuestionando la producción pero que no
solamente salen a cuestionar y a marchar
sino que están proponiendo y hace un
rato es muy precioso muy interesante del
mundo de las potencias nuevas propuestas
y eso es la que está saliendo de la
juventud y el mismo de los niños
parafraseando a director marc en el arco
24 ella dice
les dice a los líderes mundiales les
dicen ojo no estamos aquí para pedir a
los líderes mundiales que tengan
compasión de nosotros porque no tienen
un futuro
estamos aquí para avisarles
que vamos a traer un cambio que vamos a
realizar un cambio y eso es lo positivo
de todo esto el movimiento de los
jóvenes
[Música]
y he estado en la york hace unas tres
semanas aproximadamente con muchas
reuniones con ocasión de la cumbre
climática convocada por la onu
la cumbre como tal
un derroche impresionante de dinero
e
y reuniones donde no se llega realmente
a conclusiones no se presentan
soluciones en mucho menos acciones y eso
digamos genera un poquito de frustración
porque mi propia conclusión de que las
reuniones es que el cambio no va a venir
de estos líderes mundiales
los que tenemos que hacer el cambio
somos nosotros los ciudadanos de a pie
hay gente importante que si quiere hacer
el cambio pero no debemos esperar que
nuestros gobernantes en ninguna parte
del mundo lo hagan y que las grandes
corporaciones tampoco porque una gran
constatación de estas reuniones ha sido
que en la medida en que el cambio
climático no les remunere una ganancia
no les interesa
la vida de los chicos la vida de los
jóvenes no les interesa solamente
interesa en la medida en que les dé
ganas ya otra vez siempre midiendo todo
con la vara del dinero
pero lo maravilloso que es haber estado
en nueva york ha sido mirar a todos
estos grupos de niños y de jóvenes que
salían de las calles como si fueran
riachuelos y la gente los acompañaba y
se acercaban se reunían en avenidas que
seguían avanzando como ríos más grandes
ríos de florecimiento ríos de optimismo
ríos de transformación y estos ríos
que ya están funciones ya están
corriendo a nivel mundial se han vuelto
ahora torrentes en la tienda verde
los animales nos enseñan cosas
fundamentales cosas muy importantes
la más importante es que se puede vivir
mejor y ser feliz con menos
nos han enseñado nos enseñan a disfrutar
de los primeros rayos del sol a
disfrutar de los atardeceres a disfrutar
de los ríos a disfrutar de los árboles
a disfrutar que cosas de estas cosas que
nos habíamos olvidado disfrutar
su prendimiento les pregunto a ustedes
alguien me puede decir que es
verdaderamente feliz
al inicio
y otros
bien chicos
yo puedo decir lo mismo yo puedo decir
que soy verdaderamente feliz
y la abundancia de mi felicidad es
producto de tener menos
entonces se puede ser feliz teniendo
menos recuerde
les invitamos nos buscar invitarles
que compartan con nosotros
está nuestra misión que es contribuir a
generar ideologías y acciones para
lograr un mundo más sano más justo
solidario y respetuoso con la naturaleza
pero esto implica que cada uno de los
que quieran sumarse a esta arca cada uno
de nosotros tiene que deliberadamente
cambiar de rumbo recuerdan cuando
hablábamos de que nos acercábamos al
precipicio si no cambiamos de rumbo
vamos a caer en el precipicio y con eso
va a acabar la civilización tal como la
conocemos ahora
tenemos que cambiar de rumbo tenemos que
cambiar de visión tenemos que cambiar
nuestra mente y tenemos que cambiar
nuestros corazones
no es difícil les aseguro que no es
difícil pero es la única manera que
podemos hacer para poder llegar al 2020
y lograr revertir el 50 por ciento de
las emisiones de gas invernadero a la
atmósfera
si no logramos hacer eso hasta el
próximo año en venta a fines del 2020 no
vamos a pasar la barrera del 2030
la gente no quiere escuchar la realidad
y ahora se ha inventado una fecha que es
2050 no existe
lo que se dijo del año 2050 es que el
planeta el globo terráqueo para el 2050
físicamente se va a ver diferente donde
estaba norte centro y sudamérica ya no
va a haber seguramente habrá agua y si
va a cambiar como cambio el planeta
después de la quinta extinción masiva
eso es el 2050
si no logramos hasta el próximo año
revertir en un 50% recuerde
no llegamos al 2030
creemos que si se puede lograr
la situación no es buena es muy crítica
la crisis climática planetaria es
realmente muy crítica pero tenemos que
ser optimistas tenemos que agarrarnos
del optimismo para poder lograrlo
si no no lo vamos a hacer
se puede cambiar el rumbo y cambiando el
rumbo vamos a lograr transformación hay
gente maravillosa en el mundo tenemos a
gente los artistas por ejemplo tenemos a
gente como harrison ford como leonardo
dicaprio y otros millonarios que si
están dispuestos a cambiar esta suerte
fatídica ellos están dispuestos a
hacerlo se siente realmente maravillosa
hay millonarios que están donando 100
millones de dólares aquí que están
comprando territorio
para protegerlo
entonces son las cosas que nos dan
esperanza y ellos lo que están haciendo
es inspirar y hacer la diferencia
recuerden
tenemos que tener conciencia que solo
tenemos un planeta
es nuestro único hogar
no necesitamos grandes cosas en la ve en
nuestra vida necesitamos pequeñas cosas
que hagan grande nuestra vida
muchas gracias